un
papier à en-tête officiel le tampon
d'une signature françois husson lee
directeur de cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur c'est un arrêté d'expulsion
il est pris au lendemain même de la
rafle du 12 février une rafle décidée
par le juge marceau après les attentats
du début de l'année le magistrat n'avait
retenu aucune charge contre quatre
irakiens interpellés pourtant le
ministère de l'intérieur décide de leur
faire quitter le territoire ce document
concerne l'un d'eux abbas jawad envoyé
en syrie selon ses avocats c'est
exactement dans les mêmes termes qu'on
aurait justifié le renvoie dans leur
propre pays de ces deux autres irakiens
géraldine et hamza faouzi on peut donc
lire jawad et militant au sein d'un
groupe étranger d'actions violentes pas
de doute les activités politiques des
quatre hommes était bien connu leur
opposition au régime de bagdad est en
quelque sorte inscrits ici même en
toutes lettres ce même 12 février au
palais de justice un juge délégué a
aussitôt délivré une ordonnance
permettant selon la loi de garder les
étrangers indésirables en rétention
administrative
ici même au dépôt délai maximum six
jours il s'agit d'organiser pendant ce
temps les modalités de l'expulsion
voyage et surtout destination
c'est le 8ème bureau de la préfecture de
police qui va s'en charger son directeur
monsieur lacoste est en vacances ses
subalternes déclaré aujourd'hui ignorer
le dossier selon le ministère de
l'intérieur deux pays la grande bretagne
et le paraguay ont refusé d'accueillir
les deux hommes deux hommes qui
n'auraient aucunement protester
al'annonce de la destination choisie
l'irak
les circonstances du départ de faouzi et
de gerald in sont pourtant troublante
chose inhabituelle le 19 février ici à
l'aéroport d'orly c'est la dst qui les a
accompagnées elle les a peut être même
escorté jusqu'à bagdad le commandant de
bord irakien lui aussi n'aurait rien
trouvé à redire ce matin au nom des
familles un avocat a porté plainte
contre le ministre d'intérieur pour
enlèvement et complicité d'assassinât
plainte a pour but je le dis bien de
mettre le gouvernement français face à
ses responsabilités
et de faire en sorte qu'ils agissent
efficacement
et trouve
maintenant avec le gouvernement irakien
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que les
autorités françaises fassent revenir les
deux personnes exactement cela il est
important c'est de personnes revient
c'est la seule façon de sauver leur vie
et deux hommes sont ils toujours sain et
sauf de fait personne en dehors des
autorités irakiennes n'a pu les visiter